hey doing sir I was doing great
tell me sir are you a US citizen am I
being detained excuse me are you
entertaining me are you one of those
guys that's great more citizen should
know their rights no sir you are not
being detained I would need probable
cause for that in fact if you want to
get technical according to section 18
point 7 of the Border Patrol inspectors
Field Manual governing internal
checkpoints I need to have a reasonable
suspicion that you are both an alien and
inside the country illegally before I
can detain you and then of course there
are the numerous constitutional issues
at play which I'm sure you're aware of
do you have a copy of the pocket
Constitution you don't have to answer
that here I'll just give you one of mine
here's two actually that one's in
English this one's in Arabic if you need
that are you recording me is that on are
you recording me right now
oh no you don't have to answer no
according to the Supreme Court Florida
beer or Terry V Ohio you're well within
your rights not to respond
truth is I shouldn't even be asking you
about anything not directly regarding
your citizenship but hey I don't tell if
you want okay
well but you know you got me there all
right you got me there so here here's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna give you my
card
all right it's got my badge number at
the bottom and I'm I wrote my direct
supervisors email on the back there so
if you have any questions at all you
just contact us okay you don't have to
answer that either you have a good day
sir it's Cole I got an apartment
I don't consent to searches